faites comme dans l'espace je sais pas
comment on s'y prend pour s'alimenter
mais certainement que l'on ne mange pas
comme nous les terriens sur nos tables
c'est l'objet de notre entretien avec
notre invité que nous recevrons avec
plaisir pierre desproges
à propos d'un sondage que publie cuisine
et vins de france dont il est un des
collaborateurs d'ailleurs un sondage de
la sofres sur le goût des français on
pourrait le résumer ainsi qu' on
pourrait dire dis moi ce que tu bouffes
et je te dirai qui tu es
je te dire à quel parti tu appartiens
puisque dans ce sondage de la sofres
on a cherché à savoir quel était le plat
favori des français mais aussi à savoir
si les mille feuilles étaient de droite
si les socialistes avaient les mêmes
préférences que leurs alliés communistes
alors pierre vous nous avez sélectionné
quelques menus qui conviennent plus
particulièrement un communiste un
socialiste est quelqu'un de la droite
louis petit effet gestionnaire je n'ai
rien inventé j'ai repris le terme du
sondage en gros il ressort de ce sondage
culinaire que les français ont besoin de
simplicité on le sent aussi dans le
discours politique de monsieur faible du
cr il enlevait la crème il dit plus
française français et dix français tout
court mais ce nouveau langage
il a raison d'ailleurs cette française
france est ce une faute syntaxe d'âge
mais bon il ya de la simplicité et
beaucoup joué à brigitte simonetta sans
son rouge à lèvres et ravissante quand
même pour revenir à la cuisine
tchernenko sucre des fraises sans sucre
centre m oui et puis alors pour en finir
direct hommage au sang neuf
je me suis amusé à partir donc je dis ce
sondage a été élaboré en prenant les
gens par sexe par tranches d'âge et par
opinions politiques sont assez amusant
de penser à la bouffe par rapport aux
appartenances politiques des uns aux
autres en tranches d'âgés mille feuilles
et les tranches sion je pensais moi ce
qui m'intéresse de draguer généralement
dans la vie quand j'ai le temps
et alors pour draguer la table en france
c'est très important alors important de
ce sondage établit deux menus types par
exemple pour draguer une femme rpr oui
de 40 ans alors je dis 40 ans sait pas
que c'est l'âge que je préfère mon pote
mais il ya peu de femmes et reperdent de
moins
quarante ans évidemment quand même
quelque chose à faire avant alors si
vous voulez draguer une femme mûre père
vous lui servez en apéritif du champagne
ça c'est impératif
là dans la champagne les coques des
coquilles saint-jacques beaucoup de la
seule norme monde que vous arrosez de
nouveau de champagne alors qu'à mon avis
une faute de goût je suis pas ce qu'en
penserait jean ferniot qui travaille
dans la même journal que moi mais on
devrait pas servir champagne à table
mais bon elle aime bien sérieux femmes
rpr de 40 ans vous n'avez pas de fromage
ça sent pas bon
il remettait du champagne à la place du
fromage oui et vous terminez par une
charlotte aux fraises bien et même me
sens même si j'ai une communiste l'ont
bien charlotte aux fraises mais alors
justement qu'est que proposez vous à une
femme communiste du même âge de 40
langues
notre avion alors elle l est les plus
jeunes ou plus vieille non pas stéphane
communiste ses 50 ans parce que c'est
rare maintenant de trouver des fins et 1
correspond à l'âge de la ménopause
l'engagement des communistes chez les
femmes
actuellement alors donc pour draguer une
femme communiste 50 ans alors ça c'est
curieux c'est pas de ma faute mais il
faut du tout les servir tout rouge
martini et 25 bien fera pas symbolique
bowie ah oui les adore les communistes
beaucoup les femmes comme il aime le
homard qu'il rouge également je suis
vraiment bonne la faute le gigot
saignant donc également rouge
le bordeaux bruges également comme
fromage je les aime bien les camemberts
de préférence va pas citer de marque
sont classés oblige c'est l'information
le camembert le petit hic est rouge et
la sphère l'auto fraises rj également
voilà c'est drôle enfin moi
personnellement je raccroche alors
communiste de peur d'attraper la roja
est maintenant la femme socialiste alors
j'ai pas j'ai pas vu ça de près et la
vente prenait de court je peux le
revendre étudié de très près de très
près non ce que j'ai noté d'autres je
sais que les femmes socialistes les
socialistes aiment le gigot 44 46 % je
pense parce qu'ils aiment bien tenir le
manche 3 kg encore je pose sans rapport
et vous vous avez une recette dans ce
dans ce magazine qui s'appelle la cigale
melba pour personne c'est quoi ça oui
voici
je connais pas par coeur là c'est pas
choisi engagé très bref la cigale melba
oui c'est un c'est une recette qui je
sais que ça fait grincer certaines et
certains lecteurs
un vieux lecteurs de ce journal mais
c'est très bon quand même alors pour
faire une cigale mail bave quand tu es
une douzaine de cigales noter un des
cigales de la havane c'est bien sûr les
meilleurs ou les enfants c'est vivante
dans un teckel que vous aurez
préalablement museler pour inviter les
morsures évidemment vous jetez le teckel
dans un fait qui avec deux litres d'eau
salée quand l'eau frémit le teckel aussi
s'ils se sauvent vous faites revenir
avec un oignon à l'aide d'une écumoire
vous chassez le naturel
attention s'il revient le galop c'est
pas un teckel c'est un cheval d'arçons
en fin de cuisson vous passez au chinois
si vous n'avez pas de chinois vous
passez au m et puis vous servez assez
vite je m'attendais pas merci j'espère
que l'esp et les téléspectateurs ont
bien noté 7
cette recette de pierre desproges pierre
vous repartez en province pour faire
votre style de le faire mais oui je veux
tourner je commençais à limoges oui
début octobre je vais me promener en
france
[Musique]
fait étonnant non